what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a video titled
why women say i hate men and
you know being that i react to
manosphere content i feel like it's only
fair to react to both sides
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring the
notification
bell um
why women say i hate men i hate
okay before i start this is just my
analysis this woman like
what i've found is the women that are
like usually the most angry and i hate
men are the ones that are like cute
like attractive slightly above
average because they typically go for
like the top
tier guys and get treated like poorly by
themselves and when i say that
obviously it's a given that not all men
are the problem however it is a problem
that almost all women have been
by men in their lifetime
hi guys as serious of a topic as this is
i'm going to try and keep it
light-hearted because
this is for us ladies and we go through
some sad [ __ ] every single day
especially with everything going on in
the news right now
news coming forth about with influencers
our lives are
sad enough as it is right now so while
this is a heavy topic i want this to be
a safe space for
all of us to be able to vent and talk
about our feelings
and like a sleepover but it just you
know at one point or another in the
sleepover it gets a little bit intense
right like i said this
okay this is my problem with like
friendships because i can already tell i
vibe with this girl i feel like we'd get
along i just know i'm about to disagree
with everything that she says
i just i know i know this is why i have
problems
this has been a hot topic all of our
lives because we
we experienced this however it seems
like in the news and online and social
media or even people that we know
personally
um there's a lot of women coming forth
about this
and it breaks my heart so much i was
even one of those people who
gained the courage to talk about these
situations because other women were
speaking about their situations i kind
of talked about it
in my video about how i got out of an
abusive relationship i didn't go too
in-depth about it
but um i am part of the 97 and if you
don't know what the 97
is it's a study that was done in the uk
that about 97
of women is 18 to 24 have claimed that
they have been
at least once in their life which is so
incredibly sad considering that majority
of my audience
is women ages 18 to 24. i
okay so a lot of men discount the
statistic
and
you know um while i do i would say the
numbers are probably over reported
out of like my closest friends i would
say more than half have had like some
instance of sexual assault or where they
were taken advantage of
um so i wouldn't say it's 97
but i i think it's higher than the
manosphere likes to believe i'm in no
way happy at all about that number i'm
heartbroken i'm sad i feel
triggered a lot of times when i do read
stuff online but i am happy that i feel
a sense of unity and a sense of like
power within numbers in this situation
um so it makes me happy to know that i
am
really not alone with what i go through
on a day-to-day basis as a woman
isn't it interesting how when something
bad happens to you or something like
even if you do something bad either or
it not not bad like
sexual assault but i'm not like okay if
you fail a test like the worst feeling
is being like
you're the only one that failed but if
everyone failed you're like
not as mad for some reason as well as
what has happened to me many years ago i
also
wanted to talk about the stupid dumb ass
phrase that is
not all men and what i mean when i say i
hate men i hate the term
not all men because it diminishes when a
woman talks about her experiences
of what she went through i also want to
know very quickly i should have said
this in the beginning
but this is why i don't like that phrase
it's because i know
people that say i hate women because
women there are women that falsely
accuse men of sexual assault there are
women
that don't let dad see their kids there
are women that divorce their husband and
take all their money
there are women that cheat like there
are women that do all of that stuff and
i wouldn't be cool with a guy saying i
hate women so
but when i say women but i understand
what she's saying when she says
like if someone's telling you this story
of like
being harassed or whatever that if you
if you're that guy that has to chime in
and
insert your political opinions like
it's annoying i get what she's saying
this does not just include cisgender
women this is inclusive
of all women if your feminism is not
intersectional
and involving all different types of
women then your feminism is no good i
hate the term not all men because quite
frankly
um in a lot of women's experiences it is
all
men in one way or another i hate the
term but the thing is
so i'm going to win because in the eyes
of a woman who has been
it is all men because they have not had
the luxury of encountering a man
who has defended them in these
situations has stood up to them
has not associated themselves with men
who have
women or cat calder whatever else
catcalling is a form of
of course however a lot of people uh
fail to
see that oh my god i've never a woman
when in reality they just
you just cat called someone 10 minutes
ago i think additionally it should just
be
a given that when i say i hate men that
i am not saying
all men when i'm speaking but like what
percentage of men are you talking about
in all seriousness like what percentage
of men do you think are bad
because i don't know the stats off the
top of my head
but i know it's like two or three
percent like
less than five percent of men that
commit all of these crimes like it's not
the majority of men
so obviously if you're going to
categorize all men
into this scenario like they're going to
feel sometimes thinking about my
experience and i'm saying
and this is coming from someone like
i've been sexually assaulted i pressed
charges and i won
and like i'm still not going to come out
and
bash guys like a lot of these girls do
and i understand like why they feel that
way because when you've had like a
certain experience
you know that's that's how you start to
view the world but
i don't know i i don't like that phrase
men did this or men do that
i'm not speaking for every single man
and that should
be picked up on if it's not i don't know
how you got through english class in
middle school
men love to generalize women men love
white they don't even call
us women they call us females men love
to say that
females wear too much makeup females
always go after men with a lot of money
females are always dramatic but when we
say yeah
women get by men very often
not all men it doesn't make any sense
and i want to give you
but can't you be against both of those
things
like can't and that's what i don't like
that like
it's a what about is them so she's
saying oh well guys do this well
don't don't do either of those things
some examples where the
not all men rhetoric did not even apply
when i was 14 years old a freshman in
high school i had just broken up with my
boyfriend
of a week because i didn't like him very
much uh him and all of his friends
a very large sum of the football team
decided to send me a dick pic
and guess what i was made out to be the
crazy person not one single one of those
guys
had stepped in and said nicole you
didn't do anything wrong
all of those boys decided that it was
okay
a few years later when i was everyone
went against me when i moved at work
even when i was a minor and the older
men were the ones doing it not
a single person had defended me and
instead i had a male manager tell me
that it was my fault to grow up because
this was the real world
look and i'm this stuff happens more
than men
like realize like there's stuff that
happened to me when i was younger
like inappropriate things like older
guys said to me or like
guys that hit on me when i was like 16
15 or 15
16 17 that i look back in hindsight was
very creepy so i think
the manosphere underestimates how much
like creepy instances
like having um i don't know creepy
minor instances happen to like young
girls
for example i had a trainer
that basically like waited until girls
turned 18 to hit on them
so like he would hit on us when we were
technically 18 but he was like married
with kids and like trying to hook up
with these 18 year olds
like stuff like that it's not uncommon
even just a few days ago
i got a disgusting dm from someone which
was
very clearly and i decided to post it to
show awareness and also to stick out for
myself that i don't accept that kind of
stuff just because i have a following
i got angry dms from guys saying why
don't i give them attention
they're always nice to me why do i only
give attention to the bad guys
and then of course a few and i actually
don't agree
with that like mindset like
people are attracted to who they're
attracted to you can't be mad someone's
not attracted to you and a lot of guys
do they do get mad not all guys though
not all men if it is not all men what
are you
doing to ensure that are you
disassociating from all the men in your
life who
women yes okay but like ask women the
same question
do you disassociate with all the women
that like have cheated on their
boyfriends
you know seriously like i had a couple
girls on my like that volleyball team or
basketball team
that like cheated on their boyfriends
but i didn't stop like talking to them
every day i didn't have anything to do
with me they weren't like i didn't keep
them as like a close friend
but it just wasn't really my place
it goes for your friends who are
derogatory towards women and catcall
women because i can assure you
that most of you are not doing any of
those things
i'm speaking to the men here if there's
any left in this video
and to my ladies to my women you have
likely related to at least one thing
i've said in this video which makes me
so extremely sad and i'll
yeah and that's that's the part that the
manosphere doesn't
recognize always that
like most girls have had something
creepy happen to them at some point so i
know i have a lot of younger viewers
i hope that if there's at least one
thing i can do with my channel
is to boost your confidence to take down
this male dominated world i want you to
kick ass in your life
okay i want you to be strong in your
feminism and
not succumb to the internal misogyny
that we are taught every single day
how do i do that nicole you may be
asking do not succumb
to slut-shaming do not slut-shame
yourself do not
shame others i would give the opposite
advice
i do not sleep around it's not good for
your mental
health and it's not it's not good for
the way the world views you
it's like so
i don't even want to talk about it too
much but it's not it's not a good idea
here on this channel we do not [ __ ]
shame women or anyone unfortunately
something that i and i do agree that you
shouldn't like go out of your way to
like
tell someone that what they're like
doing is wrong
but like i don't know i just i would
tell young girls to wait i had to learn
growing up is that this is a
man's world do i still believe that no i
fully believe that it's my world but
i had to learn along the way that this
world was designed for men in mind and
to make
men's lives amazing and sometimes you
may have to work
so much harder than a man to get where
you deserve to be in life
get the recognition that you deserve but
in order to get there i had to learn how
to put my foot
down to get what i deserve literally
whether it's being technical
and getting that raise that you deserve
at work or even demanding respect from
the men in your life
okay so something i've been experiencing
a lot i will say that women
in general could benefit from
assertiveness training i think i could
benefit from assertiveness training
like i don't think women know how know
what they want and how to ask for it a
lot of the time
lately is tone policing i just learned
what that is women are often seen as
cold
[ __ ] rude if there are anything
besides but guys can be seen as
[ __ ] and douche bags like
i call guys douche bags all the time
bubbly and
nice i'm not a [ __ ] for being serious i
am just
that [ __ ] i don't think but i swear
some girls
will be [ __ ] and then say that they're
being toned police when they're
literally just being [ __ ]
i'm a [ __ ] for demanding respect for
being serious and i learned that i don't
have to constantly be bubbly
or crazy or extroverted just to make men
feel more comfortable in this world if
you feel
dude this is what i don't understand
like you realize being like bubbly
friendly extroverted that makes women
feel more comfortable too like i like
girls better
that are bubbly extroverted kind like
that's
it's just people follow me on instagram
you may have seen me talk about this on
my instagram stories go follow me on
instagram do it i'm being assertive i am
working on using less exclamation points
especially in my emails
especially to men i have noticed about
myself
that i use more exclamation points
especially in my emails to men
to seem happier and sis i'm not gonna
lie you're overthinking this
i'm an excited person i use explanate
explanation points
i don't know what to tell you not as
rude or not as [ __ ] um
and even using words like if that makes
sense or if that's okay or
oh my gosh i say if that makes sense a
lot
i'm sorry to bother you no no no i'm not
doing that anymore i don't care i'm not
doing it and that's what i would say
goes back to assertiveness training
like i don't think that's really because
of men
i would say that's because you don't
know how to communicate in this in
an assertive way i don't either
that's why it's why i babble on this
channel and so i'm working on that and
realizing that if other women aren't
using exclamation points that doesn't
mean that they're angry you do what
makes you comfortable but this is
something that i'm working on for myself
at least and maybe some of you will want
to as well after watching this video if
you know me then you probably know that
interrupting me is probably one of my
biggest pet peeves
ever i have a cut that's kind of what i
do
when you think about it so this channel
is as i interrupt people
virtually oh my god ties with someone in
the past for interrupting me on a phone
call i hung up on them and i never
talked to them ever again i'm being so
serious this was also like many many
years ago but still this is not me
okay i'm a girl and i think she's about
to say this is not me being dramatic but
that seems a little dramatic to me
but you know recommending cutting ties
with people if they interrupt you
however i don't regret cutting off this
person but a man okay you know maybe
interrupts you because i promise you and
they do that a lot i like to practice
using these statements which has been
mind-blowing i will tell a man straight
up and be like i
i wasn't finished talking don't
interrupt me i didn't finish my sentence
yet it's not rude
it's the truth they're rude okay we need
to stop feeling sorry for taking up
space in this world
i think this is just another way to say
assertiveness training
that's fine it's just as much ours that
is theirs something that you will
experience 100 in college especially
when there's discussions going around
or lecture halls is you will say
something and then
another student will raise your hand and
he will say the exact same thing that
you said but just rephrase it
use statements like i already said that
because guess what [ __ ]
you already did say that you said it
first and probably better i think what
i'm
damn
you know i'm just imagining her in class
and someone raising their hand and
having like a similar point to her
and her turning oh my gosh
i'm too nice i wouldn't dream i don't
have to apologize for
existing taking up space being smart
being serious and you don't also what am
i saying
nobody's saying you have to to use on a
man is
no it's very powerful i'm trying to
learn this
how to say no like better more but
for me it's not just men it's like women
once i have just established and started
feeling like i am the badass woman that
i know that i am
i started living a whole lot more
confidently
and powerfully i like to think and like
i said it definitely does not feel good
to see that
so many women have gone through
something so traumatic that is
but god does it feel good to be able to
know that you have a bunch of
sisters all around the world who have
experienced what you have
and so many that have been able to
prosper and be happy afterwards which is
why i think it's so important that
if you feel comfortable sharing your
story and you feel comfortable coming
forth about it that's why it is so
important because you never know
who else could relate to you around and
could really be touched by that because
there are so many powerful women out
there
who have shared their stories and have
influenced me to
talk about topics like this even today
here's a little snippet for my male
viewers if you're still here i've been
seeing
some infographics go around on the
internet lately
about how you can make women feel safer
in this world
i do think that those are great but
those are only great if men actually
uh do those things okay so if you are a
guy
watching this listening to this please
take these tips into account
and also share them with your other guy
friends or else
these tips are kind of pointless here
are some tips on how to make women feel
more comfortable and safer
in this world i'm not going to go into
the obvious that
is uh don't women thank you i also want
to clarify that women don't want an
apology out of men who have
done nothing wrong we're not i would
do not this is the one thing if you have
not done anything wrong do not apologize
like there is nothing that makes you
seem weaker as a person
if you're apologizing for something that
your like group
did asking you to apologize for other
men that is the last thing that we want
for you to do i saw that circulating
around as well like men being like i'm
not gonna apologize for something that
i didn't do or my friends didn't do
we're not asking for an apology we're
asking you to hold others accountable
as well as yourself if you see a woman
getting harassed or needing help
support her unfortunately men will
respect other men
more than i don't think it's that men
respect other men more i think some guys
are literally afraid of getting their
ass be i'm gonna just be
honest some guys are short
and not strong and if they see one guy
that's bigger than them cat calling in
a girl
it's not like worth the trouble you know
what i mean i'm as sad as
sad as that is to say like like
i've been catcalled before and it didn't
really like do anything like i was fine
you know i didn't get hurt
i don't think i would expect like a
stranger to go up and like threaten
some man i don't know that i can just
walk away from
over that let me know if you disagree or
agree in the comments
and women don't stay silent when you
hear your peers your family members your
good old buddy pals speak derogatory
towards women it doesn't matter if it's
in person or behind closed doors of
course it's very important that you
especially speak up if it's in person
but if you see it behind closed doors
it's a boy's night don't allow that [ __ ]
to happen
you continuously letting these
conversations happen is perpetuating the
idea that these things are okay
this is a tip for in person but keep
your distance away from women when you
are walking
at night cross the street if you can to
be away from her this was so cruel
i would actually i know a lot of guys
probably would disagree but like
i would agree with that because when
you're a girl and you're walking alone
at night which isn't something i'd
recommend
but at the same time i used to do it all
the time i
i would get pretty freaked out at times
if i saw like
a guy also like if i was alone and like
he was alone
that would freak me out so i i don't
completely disagree with that crucial
for me
when i lived in philadelphia for college
i always felt so much safer if a guy was
just walking on the other side of the
sidewalk or made sure to keep distance
away from me was not you know
running up from behind me walking too
close to me making me feel uncomfortable
you guys can't help that you're walking
at the same place at the same
time that's not what i'm asking i'm just
asking that you let it be known that
women have a right to feel uncomfortable
especially at night walking
especially because so many attacks
happen then it's not against you
personally
it's just a fear that we constantly have
because we hear
it happen to our friends and our family
members constantly keep your friends in
line and keep the conversation
going disassociate yourself from people
and friends who
have women when you stay friends with
a guy who has hurt women like that
you're basically saying it's okay or
this is where
i would i what i think happens is you
see
like rumors of someone who's like done
something but you don't actually have
proof or evidence so a lot of guys
aren't going to just cut off their
friends
if they aren't sure especially if that's
like a long-term
friend friendship um
that's what what i've seen happen anyway
or it's a pass or
it's not that big of a deal for me to be
a deal breaker and that's showing all
the women in your life
that their experiences are not worth
losing a shitty ass friend these types
of conversations and videos only go so
far but if the actions are being taken
then it doesn't matter and very
importantly
shut up and stop saying not all men god
that phrase alone makes me want to like
eat glass
while our history i would say don't say
that because it's really not worth your
breath
at that point it's so male dominated i'm
so excited for the future where
it won't be anymore and i'm also so
excited that i have a community of
92 women i feel like my comment section
is always just so supportive of each
other i know i
it'll be interesting because my comments
like my
my audience is 91 that made a lot of
controversial topics lately which
definitely should not be controversial
but
i guess they are so sometimes the
comment section can get a little bit
spicy and i anticipate that this comment
section may get a little spicy because
of the title
please don't interact with the n cells
there are so many positive people
in the comment section
i'm just trying to debate if she would
say that i'm an incel
because i disagree with a lot of what
she's saying
but i'm definitely not just so
stick to one another because it is not
worth losing the brain it's like
basically saying don't talk to anyone
you disagree with like
cells talking to them don't
don't lose brain cells um
argue or i'm trying to formulate
honestly it is my job to be filtering
out those
bad eggs out of here i love seeing you
guys comment down below
and make friends with one another and it
warms my heart especially because
so many of you guys have gone through so
many similar experiences that i have
so it's really awesome that we can just
talk and relate to one another and
feel like this is such a safe community
i remember when i was in college and i
didn't know what i wanted to do and
what my major should be or anything i
just kept reiterating to people
i just want to work with other people
and talk with people
and help others and i think about this
so often that how crazy is it that i was
able to do
exactly what i wanted to do and that is
just talking to people
okay i think she's done pretty much
um yeah i am personally not a fan
of the phrase i hate men i don't think
it's particularly helpful
uh i will say that sexual assault
is something that's more prevalent than
see i would say it's not as prevalent as
like the 97
like the feminists usually typically say
but i also think it's more prevalent
than the manosphere and like more
conservative
channels think because
like i think of like the girls i know i
would say about half
something like weird has happened to
them at some point but let me know in
the comments if you agree or you
disagree
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and i will talk to you guys
next time